good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing today
fantastic that's what I loved here
um it's Friday so as you guys are coming
in I'll tell you a quick story I don't
believe I've told you the story of how
my grandparents ended up in the US
okay let me tell you it's an interesting
story this is on my mom's side so my
grandmother uh was living in a country
called Belgium and this is the story of
how she ended up in New York which is
where she met my grandfather so she was
living in Belgium uh in a city called
Brussels and she was living there uh
just before World War II broke out and
she was about 17 years old when she was
living there and we were that side my
family was Jewish their Jewish living in
Belgium and as you can imagine that was
a bad time to be in Europe and at some
point her father had to do some business
in Germany and he went there and he was
like oh this is about to get very very
very serious so as soon as it got back
to Belgium he started selling all his
things and he didn't know how to drive
but they purchased a car and then when
the Germans invaded that part of Europe
they just left they're like they're a
couple days ahead of what we now call
the Blitzkrieg and they made all the way
to France and when I got to France
they're technically Dutch citizens so
the queen of Holland had set up five
boats and they got on one of those boats
to go to the UK four of which were sunk
by U-boats and they make it to London
just in time for the London Blitz and
then they managed to survive that too
and then get on a boat that takes them
all the way to New York where she meets
my grandfather and then they fall in
love and like that is an important part
of my story another bit of fruit of the
random tree uh speaking of Randomness
today we are going to be learning about
adding random variables which sounds a
little bit dry but we're in this part of
cs109 where we're learning about deep
Theory and this is a one of the
introductions into thinking about one of
the most beautiful results in all of
probability history
and
if we play our cards right today we will
get to see that most gorgeous result in
the world of theory uh in probability
so
that's what we're going to be talking
about before we jump in though I did
want to tell you guys about one of my
favorite parts of cs109 I'll be putting
more details about this up after class
but I wanted to announce it for the
first time today
as you may or may not know one of my
favorite things to do in cs109 is to
host what I call a personal Challenge
and a personal challenge goes like this
there are so many ways that you could
show me that you understand the material
in the class midterm is one of them but
for some people exam's not the best way
and on the other hand one of my favorite
things while learning is to give people
space to be curious to be creative and
to express themselves in the language of
what they've just learned to that extent
we Host this personal challenge you get
to do anything of Interest
in the in the context of what we've
learned in class so maybe you thought
what we learned in class was really
relevant to something in your life and
you want to create something and explore
some topic more deeply you can do a
personal challenge you'll submit um a
short write-up and or a little YouTube
video
and then we'll give you some extra
credit now this is optional in the
deepest sense of the word optional let
me give you my guarantee
if you don't participate in this
optional personal challenge your grade
walking out of cs109 will be the same as
if this challenge never existed so this
is not like or extra credit which is
going to change the curve it's extra
credit that makes it optional in the
truest sense of the word optional but if
you do this and you're able to show that
you understand this material
and maybe you show that you understand
the material perhaps even better than an
exam uh then we'll be giving you extra
credit too that will help your grade
does that make sense there's a guarantee
of optional in the true sense the word
optional I hate when an extra credit and
you're like I kind of have to do it
don't I and this is not one of those but
I do hope you participate because I
think it's just a beautiful way to
explore the material more deeply in a
way that's very personal to you and that
can make it relevant to your life I did
want to show you guys some examples
um
here's one example of what somebody made
to do
a few years back
somebody for their project made the no
humans allowed club and the way this
works is you have to enter 50 random
numbers and it tells you if you're a
computer or a human so I'm going to
start entering some numbers
oh I don't know
I'm getting there it's definitely gonna
think I'm a robot because these are
completely random and it says I figured
out that you are in fact a human like
the reverse captcha
we thought that was quite nice and
showed some nice understanding the
material
um one person
was really interested in the topic that
we taught or we're going to teach today
in class and they wanted to understand
something that I said quickly I said you
know we're going to use this result but
we're not going to prove it in cs109 she
really wanted to stand the proof so she
went deep and understood the proof and
then a YouTube video to teach other
people the proof and we thought that
this showed incredible understanding of
a Nuance of cs109 and you guys remember
um we talked about flipping Frisbees and
how a student changed or showed how the
way people start ultimate freezing games
is unfair she then came up with another
algorithm she also modeled these as beta
distributions and once in the field did
a lot of experiments and gave
probability distributions over How
likely a frisbee is to actually be a
heads all good things so there's so many
ways to combine what you find
interesting with probability uh this is
not supposed to be a representative
sample instead it's just supposed to
spark some creativity and excitement in
you guys
so there you have it the optional
challenge personal challenge you're not
competing against other people
um though you're not competing against
people the Tas will take a look and we
always will find some that just make us
so excited we give some sort of really
nice reward to them
okay
any questions about logistics before we
jump into things
we haven't graded midterms that will
happen this weekend so you'll hear more
about that on Monday
um questions concerns thoughts
okay
let's start out with a new definition so
on Wednesday's class we learned about
beta distributions and those were very
beautiful but today we're going to shift
gears into just thinking about what
happens when we add random variables but
we need to start with a new piece of
terminology that you might have seen
before but in case you hadn't I want you
to know it live it learn it love it
because we'll see it a lot in the rest
of cs109
i i d
IID stands for independent and
identically distributed
and you'll start seeing this a lot it's
very common in the world of data science
and machine learning you'll often say I
have a bunch of random variables and
then you'll see a claim and these random
variables are IID
it's a stronger claim than just saying
they're independent IID includes that
they're independent but it also means
that they're identically distributed
identically distributed is just
terminology for saying that if they're
discrete all their probably Mass
functions are the same if they're
continuous all they're probably density
functions are the same as such because
if all these things are the same you
must have the same expectation you must
have the same variance does this mean
that all the random variables are the
same
no they're not going to be the same
number they're just going to be pulled
from the same distribution
let's take this out for a spin
I'm going to give you a few different
contexts and I want you to think about
whether or not they're IID
so first one
we're going to say there's n random
variables X1 through xn
x i is an exponential with a particular
Lambda and I'm going to then claim that
all X i's are independent
so are these independent and identically
distributed
okay why don't you look at this list
we've got the first one that says you
know X i's are all exponentials and
they're all independent the second one
the only difference is that there's a
little subscript I which means that each
x i has its own Lambda
and then the third one we say that X1 is
equal to X2 is equal to X N and the last
one we say that x i all come from
binomials each with different number of
Trials but the same probability p and
then we claim that they're all
independent so talk about what the
person next to you a little bit warm up
for cs109 on a Friday which of these are
IID independent and identically
distributed okay go talk have a good
little chat and then we'll talk about
this all together
okay
yes
we're gonna do a Ruckus vote by loudness
there's no wrong answer here uh you know
this is
just practice
okay we're gonna yell the first one
IID or not IID let's say yes for IID no
for not I let's just yell
yeah
okay fantastic the first one is IID and
this makes sense because are they
independent well we've said they're all
independent and are they identically
disputed yeah they're all have the exact
same probability density function
because they're all exponentials with
the same Lambda thus if you were to plot
all their probably density functions
they would have the same curve they
won't be the same values but they have
the same distribution so I ID how about
this one a little cheeky
no
why not it looks so independent and it
looks so identically distributed
the PDFs are different why are the PDFs
different they're all exponentials
oh yeah if you have different lambdas
you'll have different PDFs that's
actually a different distribution so
even it's the same distribution family
because they have different lambdas it
won't be the exact same curve so since
the Lambda eyes assumed are not equal
these are not identically distributed
okay how about the third one
feels interesting right they're
definitely identically distributed but
are they independent
independent would mean knowing one gives
you no information about the other ones
and if I tell you one you now know
complete information about the other one
so in fact these don't fit that new
terminology definition and this is a
little bit cheeky but how about this
last one let's take it on home
no yeah because even though they have
the same
probability Mass function to be the same
and because n is different they will in
fact be different distributions
um unless of course all the NIS happen
to be equal
okay
so then I leave us with this first
question to start our day we're going
into this theoretical part of cs109 and
we've talked about random variables
we've talked about conditional beliefs
of random variables conditioned on
observing things
but one thing that seems like it'd be
interesting to do is thinking about what
happens when we apply mathematical
functions to random variables and the
simplest one to start out with is
addition what happens if you take one
random variable and add another random
variable recall that each random
variable is going to take on a value
so if I say something like you know
X Plus y
that's what I mean why oh that's X Plus
5.
if I do X Plus y That's what I mean when
I talk about adding random variables no
matter what we imagine these to be
numbers that take on values
probabilistically so it'll be this X's
number plus this wise number
but the result won't be deterministic
the result of adding these two numbers
will depend on what value X takes and
what value y takes
and I do want to explain a little bit
why you should care and there's a whole
bunch of reasons why we can just care
about addition
for example at some point we talked
about zero-sum games we talked about the
probability that the Warriors would win
and we ended up with in the world of
this thing called an ELO rating and a
zero-sum game is when two people are
playing against each other and one
person's win is the other person's loss
in the world of zero-sum games we talked
about how it could be represented as uh
uh ELO ratings which means there's like
a distribution for warriors ability and
a distribution for the opponent's
ability
the Warriors will win if their ability
was greater than their opponent's
ability
forgetting all the context and just
leaving ourselves with this we've got
what's the probability that one random
variable was greater than another random
variable when we hit this in class
earlier we punted we said we don't have
the mathematical sophistication to solve
the probably that one random variable is
greater than another
so instead we just solved it by sampling
we would just sample different pairs
from the two random variables and then
we would estimate the probability that
one was greater than the other that's
not ideal
now
if I knew how to add random variables
one of the ways that we could think
about this is we could imagine
rearranging this so it's addition it
would be nice if we could solve problems
like this so that's our motivation we'd
like to be able to add and adding will
allow us to directly solve problems but
then I gave you this hint
learning this piece of theory is an
entryway into a magical world where
you're going to see some incredible math
so this will be the first step on a
bigger more beautiful Journey
so hopefully now you understand what we
want to talk about today we want to just
talk about adding random variables and
hopefully now you're a little bit
curious It's like yeah I want to know
how to random variables I want to go to
magical journey with all my friends in
cs109 well then come on in let's go
learn
a little bit of review because we will
build on some older Concepts we've
talked about remember at the very
beginning when you're learning about
probability we talked about what's the
probability of sum of two dice being
seven
and in this wonderful space of equally
likely outcomes you could just count you
can think about all the outcomes and you
can think about here's all the outcomes
where there are two random variables
added up to seven
on some level this is a precursor to
thinking about adding random variables
and I just want to remind you of this
example uh before we jump into the more
General case of adding random variables
and the key thing to recall is that you
know if you think about all your random
variables adding up to seven you kind of
make a grid of all the outcomes and the
cases where they add up to seven would
be discrete selection amongst this grid
you could say six and one adds a seven
five and two adds a seven four and three
as seven and like luckily because these
are equally likely we could just then do
some Counting
okay and that's all we've got for review
now we just talked about the sum of two
dice and we know what happens when you
add two dice
um
and we know the probability that it adds
to seven we could also figure out what's
the probability that it adds to other
things
so if we define y to be a random
variable which is a sum of two dice
we now know how to answer the question
you know what's the probability
that y equals seven
we could also answer the probability
that y equals something else like six
and if we really wanted to we could
solve this generally and we could figure
out the probability
that y equals I and this is special if
you can tell me for any value of I the
probability that y equals I then you
understand this random variable
completely
so
assuming that all of your dice are IID
which they are two dice are independent
and they have the same distribution so
we have these two IID dice we're adding
them together and I want to reason about
the sum
and we could bump this up a notch though
like we've thought about two dice before
in class but we could easily make this
three dice we could say you know let's
sum up three Dice and see what the sum
is
I wanted to show you what the random
variables you would get if you thought
about adding one dice then two dice then
three dice this is ridiculous this is
adding one dice you roll a dice and you
add it to itself
and you're left with this probably
distribution over your values you know
you can get anything from one to six
and the probabilities are the same for
all of those
how about the sum of two dice
well we've seen this before
you know the probability of the sum of
two dice
um the chance of getting two as a sum if
you roll two dice is just one over
thirty six chance of three is two over
thirty six and you know we can work this
out using counting uh in the same
principles we had before
are you curious what the sum of three
dice looked like so I've never showed
you but you guys want to see
oh look at that
oh I saw something I heard somebody go
um
why is that kind of interesting
it looks kind of normal yeah it looks
kind of interesting well that might be
just a coincidence uh but who knows and
what happens if you sum 50 dice oh
that'd be really interesting to think
about now
uh actually do you guys want to see the
summer 50 dice oh let's go find it
code
um
some of rolls
okay
Now quickly I'm gonna 10 100 000 times
I'm going to run an experiment and in
this experiment 50 times I'm going to
roll a dice I'm going to come up with a
total sum for 50 Dice and that will be
returned from run experiment getting a
random dice will either give me one two
three four five or six with equally
likely outcomes uh and then when I'm
done I'm going to plot it just using a
histogram sound fun did you do
uh CD sum of variables
python sum of rolls
here we go
oh tqdm is so cute
um
yeah isn't that quite interesting huh
okay well we'll just we'll just leave
that and think about it
anyways but the point isn't we haven't
gotten to the theory yet but you guys
understand the problem we're thinking
about adding up random variables and of
course you have to understand the
problem before we get into the theory
and we can talk about adding two random
variables we can talk about adding three
random variables we could add up think
about adding 50 random variables and so
far actually one of the few insights I
want you to have is when you add random
variables the result is another random
variable it is another value which will
take on different numbers
probabilistically
okay
I have a thought experiment and it will
get us towards the theory of how you can
think about adding two random variables
in general here's the thought experiment
imagine there's two people and they're
playing a game where they each get
points they'll get points between 0 and
100 and importantly this is not an
interesting game like basketball it's a
game where they like all go off on their
own and independently get points so my
points is unrelated to my opponent's
points
but there's a hundred points
and the interesting thing is let's say I
know the probability that player one
gets zero points I know probably that
player one gets two points three points
Four Points any value of little X
between 0 and 100. and I know the same
thing for y they could be two different
probability distributions
but I have the probably belief of X
getting on points and probably belief of
why getting different numbers of points
and then I ask you the question what's
the probability that these two people
tie now let's just review their scores
are independent and I for any score I
can tell you the probably that X gets
that score and then probably that y gets
that score
so hopefully this thought experiment is
something you can think through but I'm
going to give you a minute just to think
about it with your friend next to you so
how are you gonna get this probability
nine
foreign
okay
now this doesn't seem that important but
if you can get this logic it's halfway
towards getting the logic of of what
happens when you add two random
variables so this isn't about adding
random variables this is talking about
the probably that two random variables
take on the same value and importantly
these random variables are independent
so if this is player X's score and this
is player y score what's the probability
that they tie
and you can think about all these
different mutually exclusive cases for
example
there's the case that they tie and they
both got 80 points
there's also the case that they tied and
they both got 79 points there's a case
that they timed they both got 81 points
and if you think about all the little
values I
which are the points that they both get
since all these cases are mutually
exclusive you should be able to just add
them
so my claim is that the probability that
these two people tie is the sum over all
the values of points that they could get
the probably that X gets exactly those
points and Y gets exactly those points
so this is going to be mutually
exclusive cases so we can add them you
know you can't both have x equals five
and also have x equals six
Mutual exclusive so you can add them all
and this is in this world they both have
eye points therefore they tie
this just gets a little bit nicer in
that because they're independent
we don't have to think about these
things jointly we can think about the
probably that x equals I times the
probability that y equals I
guess question
I would always assume
ah you cannot always it's a good
question you can't always do this
um let me see if I give you an example
let's say that
any two things that are not independent
I don't know if the first if the first
thing is like you get a a one on a dice
and the second thing is that the sum of
the two dice is like 12.
then is not the problem that you get at
one of dice times the probability that
the two dice sum to twelve even though
there's non-zero probabilities of those
things happening they can't both happen
at the same time this property is only
true if they're independent
good
results
yes
yeah
exactly exactly exactly
um so any case where they're not
independent you can't do this you'd have
to think about them jointly but if they
are independent then product of and or
probably of and becomes easy follow-up
yeah is there a way for us to visualize
this using the graphs like can we see
like how much do the two distributions
overlap and is that aside and how much
they're going to be attacked
um yeah you know what would be a little
bit easier than if you looked up there
probably Mass functions on their own
would be if you looked up a joint table
and if you look up a joint table
you know if you look up zero zero let's
say this is for x and this is for y
this cell here is probably the x equals
zero and Y equals zero and so what
you're really going to have is this
thing is going to be
all the values in the diagonal sum
together so you can see how maybe if you
made it color coded and darkness means
whether or not there's high probability
you know you can visualize how much
weight there is on that diagonal good
question
okay good yes what would phase look like
in the first one so in the case where
Define X Y we'd have to sort of convert
it to an equation so x given y y given x
what would that look like
in the case that they weren't
Independence if they're not independent
then I would probably break hmm
so
is bae is going to help you
I guess you could
if you just had one of these terms you
could use a lot of taller probability
which has a bunch of conditionals in it
but I think with both those I can't
think about how Bayes would help that
might be a limit of my own imagination
because Bayes is helpful when there's a
conditional if there's a conditional you
can flip it
well I've told probably is helpful if
you want to like go from
you know this joint to knowing one of
these on its own
um but here Independence is the most
helpful thing
let me think about this morning come
talk to me afterwards because I might be
missing something very very possible
okay more ideas
okay
so as I said that's not the thing we
wanted to get to that was just a warm-up
the real question we want is we have two
random variables and let's imagine they
could be independent or they might not
be and we want to think about the
probability of those some of those
random variables
and we want to think about the whole
probability Mass function of that sum
and if you want to think about the whole
probably Mass function of us any random
variable you have to give the
probability of that random variable
taking on the value n so the random
variable we're thinking about is the
result of adding X to Y that gives a
random variable and if you can tell me
what's the probability it takes on N for
any possible value n you have told me
what happens when you add these two
random variables
sound good
okay
here is the idea we're going to do
something very similar to what we did
with the tie
we're going to think about many
different cases that lead to these two
random variables taking on a value n
here's one case
if x takes on the value of 0 and Y takes
on the value little n what's the sum of
those two values
yeah great
um if x equals one and Y equals n minus
one what's the sum of those two values
and okay you guys are very good at this
I bet you can get this next one what
about 2 plus n minus 2. oh man all these
are different cases where these two
random variables add up to n and my
claim is this is all of the cases
my next claim is they're mutually
exclusive and then my final claim is
they're countable you know you could
have an index starting at zero and that
will be the value of x and it can go up
till n and that will be the value of x
and the value of y is always going to be
whatever X's or n minus whatever X is so
do you guys first believe my claim that
every row here adds up to n
now do you believe I claim that they're
mutually exclusive
mutually exclusive means you can't have
two rows at the same time and that makes
sense because X can't be one at the same
time that it's two
and then the final claim I make is that
this covers every possible way that you
could get n if they're discrete and I
guess if they're taking on whole number
values
okay
as such
every single one of these we can talk
about the probability that it happens
this is the problem that x equals zero
and Y equals n this is probably x equals
one and Y equals n minus one this is
probably the x equals two and Y equals n
minus two
and therefore
adding two random variables leads to
this very nice equation what's the
problem that X Plus y equals n well it's
Loop over all the different ways that
they could add up to n there is x equals
zero and Y equals n there's x equals one
and Y equals n minus one this sum is
basically just expressing the addition
of all these mutually exclusive cases
and this could be the end of your story
if you're talking about the addition of
two random variables that are dependent
if they're dependent then you have to
think about the joint probability
together
if they're independent though this isn't
the end of the story if they're
independent
then this can end up being
the sum
from I equals 0 to n the probability
that x equals I
and then probably that y equals n minus
I oh sorry if they're independent though
this will become a product of
probabilities so the probably the x
equals I times the probability that y
equals n minus I if they're independent
you can set up this equation in this
equation you only have to think about
the probabilities of each random
variable on its own independence makes
things a lot easier you don't have to
think about random variables jointly
probabilistically you can think about
them one at a time
okay
so
just putting that into slides these are
the two different rules for talking
about adding random variables this is
the general case where they might be
dependent and this is the general case
where your two random variables uh are
independent
now we're not going to go too deep into
this in cs109 but I do want to give you
the Insight that this will scale nicely
if you got to something like a
continuous random variable if you want
to talk about the sum of two continuous
random variables this sum will just
become an integral and these will just
end up being densities but we're going
to stay in the discrete world for cs109
so in some way we could have used this
to drive the graph for the sum of two
coin dice now we did this using counting
but we could have used this Rule and
this rule says that probably that X Plus
y equals n
is uh well the sum over all the
different values that X could take on
and the value that y could take on that
allows the two things to be equal to one
now first of all the probability of any
two assignment of right dice like x
equals 1 and y equals two it's one over
thirty six no matter what dice
combination you have there's one outcome
out of 36. and then the one thing that's
going to change here is the bounds you
know it must be the case
that whatever X is assigned to has to be
between 1 and 6. you can't say x is zero
because it's a dice
and dices can't be zero and the same
thing with y y can only take on values
one two three four five and six so this
exact same equation if you have
probabilities of one when these things
are both values between one and six and
zero otherwise Sorry probably one over
36 when these are both valid assignments
to dice and zero otherwise you end up
with this very beautiful chart this is
just the plotting of that equation
so at this point
do you guys now have a general rule for
adding two random variables no matter
what two random variables are you could
apply this thinking and actually you now
know how to do this thing called
convolution
back in the day this lecture used to be
called convolution do you know that
convolution is just a really fancy
probability way of saying adding two
random variables it's like whoever
talked about adding your two random
variables for the first time couldn't
just call it adding two random variables
they had to call it convolutions they
could feel really fancy but anyways if
you see convolution you should just
translate it into two things they're
talking about adding random variables
and they feel very fancy
sometimes adding two random variables
doesn't require you to go all the way to
this origin story of adding two random
verbs do you guys want to hear about
some cases where adding two random
variables is easy
okay
here's a case we're adding two random
variables is very easy you have two
different binomials they have different
values of n but they have the same value
of P
and even without going to the origin
story you can think about what is the
sum of X and Y
and do think about it meditate it on it
for a little moment what happens if you
take one binomial that's the number of
successes in N1 trials you take another
binomial which is the number of
successes in N2 trials and you add up
those number of successes
what will the result be it won't be a
constant it will be a random variable
and sometimes we call that random
variable Z
and if you add up those two things what
is z
it's a binomial
but what are the parameters of the
binomial
well
Z is number of successes in a bunch of
Trials
every trial has probability P of success
and there's N1
plus N2 trials
and that comes from it semantically you
know like X's number of successes in
this many trials with probability P why
is the number of successes in this main
trials would probably be if you add
those number of successes
it's equivalent to if you ran N1 plus N2
trials each with the same probability P
so if you add up two binomials with the
same parameter P you're in a good place
I wanted to choose High because you're
going to divide it by something no no no
just for suspense
the question was did I write N1 plus n
too high because I'm going to divide by
something no that is just poor
typography on my part
does this feel better okay
yes
every sum of any variables is another
main event
yes do you want me to repeat that or yes
that is the case if you take two random
variables and add them together always a
random variable because that result of
the sum
it's not deterministic it will vary
there will be probabilities to the
different values we'll get because
there's probabilities to the thing that
goes into the sum equation
will still follow the same model not
always not always and I'll give you a
quick example uniforms you add two
uniforms you don't get a uniform what do
you get if you add two uniforms huh
interesting mystery well we'll get there
I promise but right now we're adding two
binomials which is a good time because
if you add up two binomials you just end
up with another binomial not everything
will be so beautiful thank you binomials
for making our lives easy
and the intuition is exactly what we've
described you know X1 had N1 trials y
had M2 trials so Z has N1 plus M2 trials
all with the same probability of success
now here's a cool one
what if you tried to add up not
binomials but normal distributions and
there's this beautiful property of
normal distributions If X and Y are two
normal distributions with different
means and different variances it turns
out if you add X and Y together
you will still get it normal now this is
not always the case that if you had two
random variables you'll get the results
being the same distributional type and
normals turn out to be
exquisitely special because it doesn't
matter about their parameters you can
always add to your random normals and
get another random normal back and not
just any random normal if you add up two
normals you'll get a normal back
and its mean will be the sum of the
means and its variance will be the sum
of the variances
you may ask for me to prove that and I
think that is a very good question if
you're wondering but I'd say hold on to
that idea until we get to this more
General result from adding random
variables does that sound good
okay
you can take this to like Nth Degree
instead of adding two normals you could
add n normals and no matter how many
normals you add it will lead to another
normal and the mean will be the sum of
the means and the variance will be the
sum of the variances so that's a lot of
fancy notation which says no matter how
many normals you're adding together you
still end up with a normal with very
predictable meaning variance
and I have a final one that's nice for
you guys what if you have two poissons
so poisson X happens at rate Lambda 1
and poisson y happens at rate Lambda 2.
X and Y will represent number of
successes at their respective rates in a
fixed time interval if you add up those
number of successes you still get a
poisson and the rate of this poisson
will just be the sum of the previous
rates and that is something that we
could prove uh and I will I think there
is a proof for that in the course reader
but I want to first take a step back
because we've got three useful rules I
just gave you and I want to practice
using them
so the ReUse four rules I gave you is
the sum of two binomials the sum of two
gaussians and the sum of two poissons
particularly the summit two binomials
they have the same parameter p
the sum of two gaussians could be any
parameter and the sum of two poissons
could be any parameter and then I ask
you this question and I want to see if
you get this configured out
say you're working with the who you're
planning response to initial conditions
of a virus there's two exposed groups
and you want to know the total
probability of more than 40 infections
in group 1 50 people were exposed they
each are independently infected with
probably 0.1 in group two a hundred
people are exposed and they're
independently infected with a different
probability
in group two you add higher probability
of becoming infected and that was 0.4
and we want to think about the
probability of more than 40 infections
and I'll get it started
you can say the number of people
infected from group one is a random
variable
you can say the number of people
infected in group two is a random
variable and what we're really
interested is the sum of those two
random variables
but then there's a puzzle for you guys
you know if you think about it
this should be a binomial and this
should be a binomial can you reason
about the sum of these two binomials
why do it in your heads when you could
do it the person next to you so give it
a shot think about it with the person
next to you because this is a classic
example of what a problem on a problem
set could look like with the sum of two
random variables
um
laughs
yeah
okay
there's many paths to answers here
there's one path to be avoided and then
there's two happy paths that will get
you the right answer
so
I know let's throw up some ideas
well I got bored let's brainstorm
s and that's one minus probability that
one minus the something that x y equals
I
um and then as we know that formula can
be for X Plus y equals n we can
substitute that in but yeah
foreign
so one strategy is
we have this formula
we think the values of X1 which is the
number of people infected in group one
is independent of the number of people
infected in group two there are two
random variables but they're not
influencing each other
uh and we could use this fundamental
definition of adding two random
variables so we can think about the
probability that X1 equals like if you
want to say like what's the probability
that the sum of two random variables is
zero well that's probably that x one
equals zero and X2 equals zero if you
want to know the probability the sum of
two random variables is five then we
have to think about looping from X one
equals zero up to five and X2 is equal
to whatever the complement is this first
principle approach will 100 work
but there's another way
and there's a question or an idea
well I just thought that we could
convert the binomial we could
approximate it to a poisson and
like Lambda is PN so
um in the first case
where every 50 people it would be Lambda
would be five for 50 people and the
second case it would be
like 4 400 people so basically you
convert the first case into 100 people
as well yes let's just add the two
questions so many things that I
absolutely love and I want to
deconstruct
first of all you said approximate the
binomials and there's something very
special about that Insight before you
even get there
you might think hey don't we have a rule
for adding two binomials we've already
talked about what happens if you add two
binomials you get this thing I said
adding two binomials is easy you just
add up the number of experiments
but why did you want to approximate why
didn't you want to just use this
equation because p is different ah p is
different this simple equation I gave
you for binomials only works if p is the
same therefore you thought I'm going to
use approximation
and then you thought I'm gonna use the
poisson approximation everything you
said after I'm going to use a process on
approximation was correct right all
those ideas for how you would get
lambdas but the only problem is poisson
is meant for extremes extremely large
and an extremely small probabilities of
p and I could argue that this is Extreme
but since probably 0.4 isn't that
extreme your poisson approximation here
will be okay and you'll get a pretty
good answer but it won't be that tight
in approximation
but let's plus that answer let's take
that answer and think okay poisson is
not extreme this is an extreme enough
for poissa who can play if we want to
play the approximation game yeah
binomials can be approximated by a
poisson or normal so you could say that
I will get the approximate normal for
this one I'll get the approximately
normal for this one and normal
approximations are happy you know when
everything looks moderate the variance
check that we gave you works out for
both of these numbers and it turns out a
normal approximation does work
now both of these were good paths in
that there's an easy way to add up
poissons and there's an easy way to add
up normals so if you can turn your
binomials into one of these worlds we
can think about convolution
Yeah question do I have another approach
oh yeah fantastic okay I was thinking of
doing like almost like a summation that
is as we came back to the table that we
had earlier yeah with all the N minus I
think uh-huh and then you have like you
start by like n is equal to 40. and then
you go n is equal to 41 and is equal to
42 so you sum through and it's equal to
40 and then you add to that the sun
through n is equal to what you want
so somewhere in here
there's the line and it'll actually be a
zigzag because they're discreet and at
this line if you take y's value and X's
value it sums to 40. this is like sum to
40 line
uh and your Insight is if you want to
know the probability of more than 40
infections then you can just add up all
the probability Mass over here
and you can figure out like what's
probably of every single Grid in this
and that that would also work
okay
I love it I love it these are many good
approaches to solving this problem
now
the first question I just have is should
we use a binomial sum of random variable
shortcut and hopefully at this point
you're like no that binomial sum of
random variable shortcut was only when P
was the same yeah
how do uh how do we see that it's easy
to add in personas this seems
non-intuitive you could actually work it
through so poisson is one where we can
actually go to this first principle
definition
and if you say they're independent
poissons and you think about these
probabilities if you put in the
probability Mass function you will be
able to factor it into a new poisson
that's a cool question it is unintuitive
why don't I show you the proof
okay
so
is that fact like true more deeply
because croissants are like emerged from
poisson processes there's two ways to
think about it mathematically if you did
that first principle thing you end up
with another fossil and the other way to
get it is to think yeah poisson
processing is mean these independencies
and also like there's this convolved
rate then you can get into your head
about it but I believe the math when I
saw it
um okay if you want to go down the path
of the normal approximation this is what
it would look like instead of just
having a which is the true binomial in B
which is the true binomial for group two
I had approximating normals I say x is
my approximate normal and you can figure
out what that is turns out mean is 5 and
variance is 4.5 and Y can be
approximating normal for the second
group mean is 40. variance is 24.
the probably that you know the sum is
greater than 40 is the probability it
was very similar to the probability that
the sum of your normals is greater than
39.5
39.5 what happened to that half a person
yeah sorry pal continue correction
you're out of here it's not actually
half person missing that's just because
we went from a discrete and we
approximate with A continuous and
whenever you do that you have to think
about half a unit
um and which direction you have to
include
so this is very similar to the question
what's this probably that some of these
two normals greater than this value if I
call my sum of two normals w
that W will have a known distribution
you just add up the means of the two
normals you summed and you add up the
variances and you get a new probability
distribution W which is in fact a normal
and if you want to ask the probability
that W is greater than 39.5 that's
asking what's the probability that this
normal is greater than 39.5
I switched from W to X how embarrassing
but anyways it's 1 minus the CDF at 39.5
and you can just plug that in either
through the five formula or you could
use the scipycdf
cool yes
um so how do you get the five and four
point five like how do we get the
parameters of the normal from just the
Lambda like so so from the nnp values
that we have with the binomial it's a
very good question okay and I'm going to
switch these to W's
how did you get five here
the idea is if this is a binomial and
this is the approximating normal you
should choose the mean here which is the
same as the mean of this binomial what's
the mean of a binomial well that's its
expectation which is if you look up the
formula n times p and 50 times point one
is five
what's the variance of a binomial if n
times P times 1 minus P which will be 5
times 0.9 which is 4.5
so that's how you figure out the
matching uh values for mean and variance
if you're doing your approximating
binomial
okay
now
I showed this to some students and
people went away happy and then one
student came back very unhappy he says
Chris there's a contradiction two things
you've told me in cs109 and I cannot
sleep at night can we talk about it
and he posed this question to me he said
Imagine X is just some normal
and I'm going to add X Plus X
there's two ways of thinking about X
Plus X you could think about it as the
adding of two random variables or you
can think of it as x times two you know
whatever x value is I'm going to
multiply by 2.
earlier in class you said if Y is a
linear transform of a normal you'll end
up with another normal and I gave a way
of talking about what that other normal
will be particularly I said
if Y is equal to a linear transform of
normal take that normal take the
constant and multiply the mean by the
constant and then the variance will be
multiplied by that constant squared so I
said this earlier in class
but now I just told you how to think
about the sum of two gaussians I said
you know if Y is equal to X Plus X you
can think of this as the sum of two
gaussians and I just told you if you add
two gaussians you'll get another
gaussian well that doesn't seem to
contradict yet and the mean will be the
sum of the means and the variance will
be the sum of the variance
and you're left with this
it looks so similar
through these two different approaches
both of them lead you to conclude that
the sum of these two gaussians is normal
and both of them lead you to conclude
that the mean of this sum will be two
times whatever the mean of X was
but they have different answers for the
variance
and the student couldn't sleep and came
as like there's something wrong in the
world of mathematics this is like does
this go deep is there something wrong
with addition two are you lying to us
and the answer is no there's just one
really interesting subtle Point here and
it's worth talking about because it's an
assumption that we've made
foreign
[Music]
uh well are they here x
and X are they independent no
that's it
now X is not independent of the same
random variable X if you see X Plus X
and there's the same random variable
what this implies is like roll your dice
for X get its value
and then add that exact same value to
itself so if like X turns out to be four
then this is also four you end up with
four plus four x might turn out to be
five then you get five plus five but no
matter what this and this value are the
same that's why we could write it as
equal to 2 times x
but therefore if I know the value of x
does that tell me anything about the
value of x
yeah
they're not just missing Independence
they're completely dependent
um and the sum of two gaussians rule
that I told you assumed Independence of
the gaussians the sum of two poissons
that I told you assumed Independence and
the sum of two binomials I told you
assumed Independence
okay cool moving on so anyways so now we
can all sleep at night and there is a
bug here which is that X is not
independent of X very good
okay let's go back to zero sum games so
I promise that we'd be able to think
about uh the probability that the
Warriors win in a zero-sun game we've
already talked about how this can be
represented as ELO scores
you can think about every team as having
an ability and is drawn from a normal
distribution the mean is like how good
the team is and the variance depends on
the sport in the original ELO paper and
they set basketball to be 200 squared
the idea is that both teams when they
play they're going to sample from their
ability of distribution and whoever has
the higher sample ability wins this is
the theory of Elo it's not actually how
basketball Works they actually play a
game with the ball and two Nets
and then we ask the question what's the
problem that the Warriors win
and we've talked about how this is
before is what we think about the
Warriors ability random variable and the
opponent's ability random variable and
this is really asking what's the problem
the Warriors pull a value that's greater
than their opponents
and to give you plots for what this
could look like the Warriors have a
random variable it could look like this
normal the opponents have a random
variable could look like this normal
we're asking what's the probability that
this random variable is larger than this
other one
my claim for you is that this is an
addition question
asking if one random variable is larger
than another is the same as addition and
you're like what that doesn't sound like
Edition sounds like inequality and just
to be clear you know like if we say that
this random what's the chance of this
random variable is larger than this one
it says this random variable will take
on a value let's say it's this and this
random variable is going to take on
value and it could be this one but
that's very unlikely more likely it
could be something like here and we can
think about what's the probability that
this value is greater than that one
and I claim it's addition insanity
okay
here is why it's addition
I give you your two normals for your two
random variables I asked what's the
probably one random variable is greater
than the other and then my next claim is
this is the same as if you were
subtracting one random variable from
both sides you get what's the
probability that the difference of these
two random variables is greater than
zero
so hopefully at this point you believe
that the probability of one random
variable being greater than the other
one is actually a subtraction question
it's probably that the subtraction of
two random variables is greater than
zero
but
if you recall if you take a normal
distribution and you do a linear
transform like you take that random
variable and multiply by say negative
one you'll again get a normal
that negative one will be multiplied by
the mean and the variance will be
multiplied by negative one squared
so negative of the important stability
will be this gaussian
and if you add up this gaussian and this
gaussian which we just derived
the sum because they're independent will
be another gaussian and we can get the
probability of the difference between aw
and a0 as a random variable you'll add
up the means the mean of aw is 1797 and
the mean of negative AO is negative one
five five five we add those two numbers
together you get 242. you add up the
variances and both of them have variants
of 200 squared so adding up the variance
will give you 2 times 200 squared
and now you can ask what's the problem
that this difference is greater than
zero it'll just be equal to 1 minus the
CDF and that's something you could look
up and you can end up with the
probability of 0.804 before we had to
sample to get this answer and now we
don't need to
okay
okay the convolution will not be
televised okay
now
I want to mention quickly that it's not
always so Rosy
we've talked about binomials some was so
nice if they had the same P we talked
about normal if they're independent the
sum is so nice and poissa they're
independent the sum is so nice anybody
like
sums are always going to be so beautiful
and I just want to for a moment look at
the scary world of how this can all fall
apart
uniform
so uh just really quickly I hope you
believe me but you know if you want to
talk about the sum of two discrete
random variables we have this formula
so the probability that sum comes to a
is just going to be a minus uh or the
probability that
um you know one of the random variables
equals whatever you're looping over in
the probably the other random variable
equals your target minus the index
and there's a continuous version too and
then the continuous version It's the
exact same thing it's just become a sum
becomes an integral and probability Mass
function becomes probably density
so what happens if you add our good
friend a uniform between zero one with
our other good friend a uniform between
zero and one
just to be clear these are the two
uniforms that we're trying to add
together
so we're trying to add two uniforms they
both have probability density that are
equal to one in the range zero to one
and if you think about it you could ask
the question If X is uniform
and why is uniform and particularly
we're going to say their uniform with
zero one
what's the probability that X Plus Y and
this should be density
what's the probability that X Plus y
is equal to some number and we could say
something like 0.2 to start out with
of course we're going to want to think
about this in all the different cases
but what is the probability that the X
Plus Y is equal to 0.2
yeah
no it could happen oh well the probably
density
probability is zero but the probability
density is going to be non-zero
um
and the claim the The Continuous
equivalent of this is that it's going to
be the integral
over some Loop and we'll think about as
bounds in a second
and this will be the likelihood that X
equals I
and Y equals
0.2 minus I
so we're going to integrate will be like
what's the chance that x equals you know
0.1 and then y also equals 0.1 because
then they would sum up to 2.
now the nice thing is
both of these values are ones you know
if you look at the the PDF value of both
of our uniforms it's ones so it feels
like we have the integral of one
the tricky thing is to think of what are
the bounds on I
such that these two things don't give
you zero because if you ask what's the
probability that your uniform is less
than zero it's zero and you're probably
that your uniform is greater than one
that's also zero so what bounds are
going to make both of these non-zero
well I'll tell you what from this one
we know that I has to be greater than
zero and less than one
because if I is between those two values
this is just one otherwise it's zero and
zero multiplied by zero is zero so I
already know that I has to go from zero
to one for this value
but how about this one
this is a super tricky bound work but
if I takes on the value 1.
what is 0.2 minus one
negative 0.8 it's a negative number and
what's the density of our uniform at
negative 0.8 it's like asking what's the
density over here
ah it turns out if I gets too large this
thing will exit the range of being in
the CDF of Y one of our uniforms
so the bound over here what's the
biggest value that I can be such that
this doesn't exit the range of being one
yeah if it ever becomes greater than 0.2
then this will become a negative number
and you'll be get a density of zero if
it's between 0 and 0.2 then this will be
a number that is positive and less than
one and this dense will be one so in
this range from I equals 0 to 0.2 you
end up with one times one
so this will be equal to this density
you know d i in this case uh and if you
did this integral it would just end up
being 0.2
and this is looking pretty good you're
like oh that doesn't feel so bad
if you want to think about this you know
you could think about different points
we just thought about point two and we
found out that the density
that the sum of the two uniforms is
equal to 0.2 is equal to 0.2 and you can
try a bunch of these points
if you did it you'd realize that the
answer is piecewise in fact if you're
thinking about the in sum of two
uniforms being up to one it just
linearly increases as we asked what's
the probably the sum of two uniforms is
one half it's one half well it's
probably the sum of two uniforms is
three quarters it turns out to be three
quarters for a very similar argument to
here but then after you get to one then
your bounds work changes and it starts
to go down
now you could do all that work piece by
piece it just turns out that the uniform
if you add two uniforms you certainly
don't get a uniform instead you get this
weird triangle thing
so the sum of two random variables isn't
always a clean answer and uniform really
drives that point home the other thing
to note is you know if you want to think
about the sum of two continuous random
variables it'll be just what we talked
about before just with integrals and
densities
now I want to point out one cute thing
remember we talked about the sum of two
dice and dice are quite similar to
uniforms and that they're equal
probability of every outcome and you got
the sum of two dice looks like this
triangle and now we have the sum of two
uniforms looks like that triangle
is there a conspiracy going on question
yeah if you had not zero to one you
would end up with different bounds work
over here and you get you know different
shape triangles
still a triangle though suspicious this
is where they hide the treasure no okay
um
but then you might wonder what happens
if you add up 100 uniforms and the
beauty is we can do this we've got
computers if we want to not just think
about the sum of two uniforms what if we
wanted to think about the sum of 100
uniforms if I wanted to do this
um
what I would probably do is I would set
up this code
and in this code I would run 10 000
experiments every 10 000 exp every
experiment though I'm going to sum up a
hundred uniforms
I'm going to get a list of all those
sums and then I'll plot the histogram
does that sound like a cool thing to do
so every experiment I do exactly this I
do convolution of 100 uniforms
so we know that the sum of one uniform
is just this
so the sum of one uniform is just that
we know the sum of two uniforms is just
that what is the sum of a hundred
uniforms going to be
oh I don't know but
we can be experimentalists
and we can go to sum of variables and we
can do python 3.9 sum many UNIS
here comes the suspense it's going it's
going it's going to do this ten thousand
times tqdm is so nice it does this like
really cute bar check it out it's not
that important right now what is
important is getting really close to
seeing your answer and your hypothesis
oh
wow
it was pretty skinny but when we
readjust it
what does that look like
what maybe there is a deeper mystery
maybe there is a conspiracy all along
because we added up Dice and we got a
gaussian and then we added up uniforms
and we got gaussian and now you're
thinking there's something special about
Dice and uniforms that gives you
gaussian and at this point you're like
I've gone crazy but I'm still gonna do
it what happens if I add up a lot of
beta distributions
so we learned about beta distributions
yesterday you know they don't look like
uniforms at all and said they look like
these little uh little bumps that
represents distributions of
probabilities that's not important right
now I'm going to think about adding 100
betas together IID betas so they all
have the same distribution and they're
all independent I'm going to add 100 to
them I'm going to do it 10 000 times and
we're going to find out what happens if
you add up betas you guys ready
there it goes what do you think what you
imagine happens if you add 100 betas
beta is a weird thing to think about
what's convolution is going to be
I don't know maybe it's going to look
like another beta
yeah it could be another beta
something is weird in the world of
probability
oh it turns out if you did 100 plus
songs the same thing happens like trust
me if I were to do the same experiment
replace the beta with the poisson again
you would see something that looks like
a gaussian
now let's have our moment of silence
before we present one of the most
beautiful results in an entire history
of probability Theory a result that's
profoundly important as it is profoundly
beautiful
foreign
this is not a coincidence there is
something beautiful and magical in our
world and this beautiful magical thing
in art world is no matter what random
variables you have if they're IID if you
add up enough of them they always
converge to a normal distribution
betas uniforms poissons just your
friends random variable that they drew
on a graph
if you draw enough samples from that
random variable in the graph and you add
them up the resulting random variable
will be a gaussian
and not just any gaussian
if you add up IID random variables no
matter what they are they could be
gaussians betas your friend's
distribution you'll get a normal and the
normal will have a mean which is equal
to the mean of the underlying random
variable of drawing from
Times by how many experiments you ran so
if you ran you added up 100 uniforms
this will be a hundred and this will be
the mean of your uniform and the
variance will be a hundred times the
variance of the uniform or replace
uniform with whichever distribution it
came from
IID is important so the sum of niid
random variables is normally distributed
with a calculatable mean and variance
and it's beautiful and it's gorgeous and
I could talk about how beautiful and
gorgeous this is in so many different
ways
one way to talk about is it explains why
we saw this you know some of one dice
roll uniform sum of two dice rolls
starts to look like a triangle but you
sum three dice rolls and already it's
starting to look like a normal
distribution
we can go deeper into the proof in fact
I will share that video that one one of
the personal challenges back in the day
and that goes over the proof for why
this is true
but to give you an intuition for why
it's true
when you add two dice world together why
is there more weights in the middle
because there is more ways to get a
seven than there were to get it two
and when you add three dice rolls
together you know the same thing happens
there's just way more ways to get
something close to the average value on
a dice times three
than there are to get things that are in
the extremes so that starts to give you
some intuition but I'll give you that
YouTube video If people want to go a
little bit deeper
it explains so many things it explains
why
when you have a binomial and you look at
its distribution it looks like a
gaussian that wasn't a coincidence that
wasn't a hack it comes straight from the
central limit theorem why does a
binomial always look like a gaussian
because a binomial under its hood is the
sum of independent random variables
you're like which independent random
variables I thought a binomial was just
a binomial no no
a binomial is so much more
if I say you have a binomial so X is a
binomial
with n equals 100 and P equals 0.4 or
0.5 let's say
my claim for you is that X is the sum of
IID random variables and particularly x
equals the sum
from one to a hundred
of y i
and what is y i y i is a single
Bernoulli representing a coin flip so y
i is your Bernoulli
with 0.5
so if y i is a single coin flip with 0.5
these are IID random variables
and the sum of Y IID random variables
will always be well approximated by a
normal
that binomial approximation by normal
comes from the central limit theorem yes
part two
anyways
uh we talked about okay so the sum
the approximation of binomial from a
normal comes from this deep idea that we
have on the board it's that the binomial
itself is the sum of bernoullis and
particularly you know if you thought
about it through essential limit theorem
it's say that the good approximating
normal would be equal to n times the
mean of your Bernoulli but the mean of a
Bernoulli is just p and the variance of
Bernoulli is just P times 1 minus p and
you end up with the exact same
approximation whether or not you use
essential limit theorem or you use our
normal approximation idea from before
and just to drive this home
this is a random variable it doesn't
have a nice equation instead it has a
probably Mass function defined by like
some crazy person just drawing a plot
but if you took samples from this and
added them together you would end up
with the sum of IID random variables so
if you took 15 samples from this and
added them together
you would get something where the sum is
distributed as a normal and that's just
driving home the point that the central
limit theorem doesn't require the
underlying thing to be a clean
distribution
all it requires is that the things
you're adding together are IID wow
that's so cool fantastic whatever you
take this distribution you add them
together you get a normal
okay what a good time now we only have
five more minutes
and it's a Friday and you guys have
worked hard so maybe let me finish this
example then I want to leave you with an
idea of why I think this is so beautiful
you might ask the question how good is
the central limit theorem and to answer
that question one thing I could do is we
can take uniforms
and we could take the convolution and we
could compare it to the normal
approximation
if you talked about Central limit
theorem where you thought of n equal to
2 so the sum of two independent uniforms
the true answers in the dashed line and
the central limit theorem is in the uh
the Orange Line already this looks like
a pretty good approximation but there's
some error and you can figure out what's
the exact answer and you can figure out
what is
the central libid theorem answer and you
can see the central limit theorem would
give you a different answer to the
question like what's the probability
that the sum is less than say two over
three
but what have we got to three if you add
up three uniforms you get this dashed
line but the central limit theorem would
say that it's approximated by this
orange line and already if you start to
ask probability questions you'll get
very very similar answers and if you
bump it up to something like 10
the sum of 10 uniforms is so perfectly
represented by the central limit theorem
that any probability question you get
you're going to be so incredibly close
if you use the CLT
okay
if there's a major takeaway from today
one you learned how to do convolution
you learned how to add random variables
you solve some cool problems with that
we learned some cool tricks
then we bumped it up a notch and we
started to realize that the convolution
of any IID random variables always gives
you a normal which is a beautiful thing
now
if I could we'll talk about this later
but if the sum of IID random variables
is normal I want you to think what is
the average of IID random variables
because sum was just one approx one
operation we did you could also think
about average you could also think about
a thing called a Max I'm going to leave
that for you guys to think about and we
can pick it up on Monday's class but I
want to leave you with
one a little bit of history and a quote
so if you guys are curious about the
history of this this comes from Abraham
de Moi and in fact he was a refugee who
left France because he was a hug you
know who was being persecuted he ended
up going to the UK because of that he
wrote the doctrine of chances in English
and because of that UK became the place
for Bays to come up with bayesium like
the whole history of mathematics starts
from this person being a refugee and
having to leave France and therefore not
writing the doctrine of chances in
French doctrine of chances is where the
central limit theorem was first shown
he first showed it for a sum of
Bernoulli's
it was then taken by LaPlace and they he
did the first proof that a binomial can
approximate as a normal
and then finally the precise definition
of the general version of the central
limit theorem was given by Alexander in
1901 and then you know whatever about
the Beyonce thing I'll explain that
later
um we're gonna play a game later on
Monday we're going to start with a game
where we're going to think about Central
limit theorem but I would like to leave
you with this idea
this is a quote from Galton on the
central limit theorem
I know of scarcely anything so apt to
impress the imagination as a wonderful
form of cosmic order expressed by the
central limit theorem
the law would have been personified by
the Greeks and deified if they had known
of it it reigns with Serenity in
complete self-effacements amidst the
wildest confusion of adding random
variables
the hunger the Huger the mod the more
random variables
and the greater the apparent Anarchy the
more the variance the more perfect is
its sway it is the supreme law of
unreason whenever a large sample of
chaotic elements are taken in hand and
marshaled in the order of their
magnitude adding and unsuspected and
most beautiful form of regularity proves
to have been latent all along it is a
beautiful thing about our universe have
a fantastic weekend come back on Monday
and we'll continue this beautiful Deep
dive into theory of probability thank
you very much cs109